chéri le coup de griffe du jour c'est
kelly qui la wii qu'est-ce qui se passe
alors c'est un coup de griffe mais moi
c'est un coup de griffe que je fais
aussi pour les autres parce que j'ai de
la chance je sais pas pourquoi mais en
tout cas je n'ai pas énormément de
problème moi avec internet mais j'ai
décidé quand même d'essayer de me
pencher sur qu'est ce qui se passe dans
le cerveau d'un haters
voilà j'ai voulu plancher sur ça et je
me suis dit pour essayer de les
comprendre
eh ben je vais essayer de leur répondre
et discuter avec donc j'ai une grande
conversation avec un débiteur
il ya deux jours sur twitter on a
beaucoup énormément parlé et on est
tombé hier sur avec raymond sur une
demoiselle qui s'appelait kenza jlassi
tu as bien dans le public de temps en
temps et je suis tombé sur un truc alors
d'habitude elle nous aime bien et là je
vois qu'elle est elle dit à raymond
sueur avec un c'est au milieu et je me
dis tiens c'est dingue cette fille là
elle est gentille locaux voulaient pas y
aller c'est dingue et après l'écrit ftg
des choses comme ça et tout je me dis
mais tu fermes ta gueule
sidimé deux publics ou pas je me suis je
vais un petit peu la taquiner et mettre
dans la peau lighters juste le temps de
deux trois tweets pour voir comment elle
est le prendrais et qu'est ce qui se
passe dans sa tête et j'ai vu que ça se
passait pas très bien dans sa tête et je
me suis dit que c'était peut-être à
étudier parce que j'ai l'impression que
ce que ces gens là eh bien ils se
rendent peut-être pas compte de l'impact
qui balancent des mots comme ça et qu'il
ya certaines personnes qui peuvent mal
le prendre
merci on s'est un petit peu alors on va
voir le récap un pays parce que c'est
hier on a parlé du cas camélia jordana
qui avait dit donc cette chanteuse dont
qui avait fait à nouvelle star qui avait
dit chez laurent ruquier que voilà elle
a parlé des violences policières
elle a dit surtout ce qu'on a sont à
charrier nous c'est qu'elle a dit voilà
je veux un débat avec christophe
castaner le ministre de l'intérieur
alors franchement oui que quelqu'un voit
la demande un débat avec christophe
castaner oui moi je préfère que
christophe castaner soit face à plein de
jeunes de cité plein de jeunes de
banlieues qui viennent lui poser des
questions bien sûr il faut que face à
camélia jordana je trouve que ça serait
l'émission est d'ailleurs on va essayer
de le monter dans btp voilà avec le
médium et suez mise d'intérieur ou
christophe castaner lui-même voilà on
essaiera de le monter dans btp je vous
le dis
avec christophe castaner planète à la
rentrée avec moi là plein de jeunes qui
viennent lui poser des questions
ça serait bien ça serait bien mais
camélia jordana qui dit nous on n'a rien
contre elle je vous dis je la connais
pas du tout mais qui dit je veux un
débat avec avec christophe castaner ont
prouvé que c'était un petit peu voilà un
petit peu disproportionné regardez petit
récap s'est bâti en quelques années les
réseaux sociaux sont passés de
plateforme de communication et d'échangé
permettant à chacun d'exposer son avis
et ses passions un gigantesque octogone
ou chacun donne des coups et tente d'en
éviter
hier c'est kelly qui a craqué sur son
compte twitter une nouvelle fois
victimes de ses insultes devenues
monnaies courantes alors que plusieurs
internautes s'en prenait à raymond elle
a décidé de répondre et de bloquer
tonight heures dans un ultime message
elle est tenu à prévenir les concernés
avoir de la maturité c'est se laisser
mal parlé mais vous êtes tous des tares
et salue les débilos un ras-le-bol de
plus en plus perceptible chez les
personnalités publiques victimes
régulièrement de lynchage face à ce
phénomène devenu incontrôlable la
plateforme twitter a décidé de tester
ces dernières semaines de nouvelles
options sur son site avec par exemple la
possibilité d'interdire aux internautes
de répondre à 100 tweets pour éviter
toute provocation
alors mes mots hier on n'a pas de
camélia jordana s'était fait insulter
aurait mon nom parce qu'hier j'ai parlé
de camélia jordana c'est vrai que je
suis parti dans les toilettes en scope
tweet encore hier grâce à ça et même
aujourd'hui grâce à camélia jordana pas
encore ça mais moi j'étais là je me vois
c'est génial content de ma famille ça
génial effet sultan de quoi c'était fou
et puis je voudrais remercier tout
trouvé voilà tous mes fans tout ce qui à
chaque fois prennent le temps vraiment
de répondre à chacun des acteurs
ils sont exceptionnels voilà j'en ai
clan tête à l'insularité bleus loïc je
me fais tous ces sites et voilà mais il
y en a plein âge hip hop voilà j'adore
aussi j pop us ce qui est exceptionnel
bon il y en a plein à elodie voilà tous
voila mais voilà je voulais vous dire
vous embêtez pas avoir parce qu'ils ont
toujours peur que ça me fasse un malaise
serait pas de là mais vous pouvez leur
dire voilà les séries
franchement nous embêtez pas avec ça
voilà moi quand je vois mon nom au top
tweets je suis content c'est pas
permettez moi de vous poser cette
question car il est assez surprenant
parce que ça glisse sur vous comme sur
les plumes d'un canard et c'est quand
même très étonnant parce que malgré tout
je sais que vous êtes un surhomme mais
je dois même un homme et ça peu du mal à
concevoir que ça ne vous atteignent pas
à ce point là je vais vous dire parce
que je vais vous dire je suis voulu dire
non mais il faut pas essayer d'être les
lecteurs il vous aimons vous sert à rien
d'aller leur parler hein pas un pour
qu'ils essaient de vous aimer c'est leur
truc
il aime bien faire ça il existe à
travers ça un jour saadna qu'ils aiment
pas le lendemain ce sera quelqu'un
d'autre il faut les laisser seller qui
boit trop ce mot est à la limite
voilà moi ça me fait rire voilà ça me
fait plutôt marrer parce que même il ya
des haters qui me font énormément rire
qui me font des vannes tout ça je me dis
que j'ai réglé aujourd'hui devait
reprendre ce soir
et moi j'adore quand on vannes françois
même quand on insulte ça ne dérange pas
voilà à part quand ces deux visions mais
sinon heureusement c'est assez
sympathique voilà moi c'est un fait
plutôt rire je vous dis franchement je
le prends bien ça me fait marrer
vous l'avez vous avez décidé que c'est
la règle du jeu et sabra bravo à moi il
ya eu un truc pour la qui m'avait l'air
je vous dis la vérité
il ya eu un tweet qui m'avait l'air
vraiment de toute l'histoire c'est quand
j'avais mixité anniversaire de mon fils
est un abruti qui a dit j'espère qu'il
va passer un mauvais anniversaire
s'assurer un abruti à la fin vous
inquiétez pas je les localiser je vais
le retrouver
c'est la voix l'anonymat classés b ça
c'est très bon non mais moi je trouve
twitter que c'est quand même bien je
trouve c'est bien moi aussi voulu
j'aurais voulu moi quand j'étais plus
jeune quand j'avais 20 ans pouvoir
parler à des gens connus qui passe à la
thèse d'un croc je trouve que c'est un
outil merveilleux parce que tu peux
échanger
tu peux parler tu peux débattre hier sur
camille à moi je vous savez vous me
connaissez j'ai créé un jeu près pas
rien je parle comme ça vient et je trace
et parce que vous travaillez jeudi les
jeux dit que des conneries et quand je
dis camélia l'est pas dans les cités ma
chance je veux je veux pas qu'on mettre
de l'huile sur le feu et sur twitter
jeudi je trouve que c'est vachement bien
parce que tu peux débattre avec les gens
d'accord pas d'accord sauf que quand tu
te fais insulter une fois ouais on te
fait une insulte tu laisses passer deux
insultes tu laisses passer au bout de la
troisième
moi je peux décider aussi de bloquer la
personne je pense j'ai pas envie de
d'entendre tes insultes en fait je
trouve que c'est vachement bien
d'échanger mais insultes jets pablo
cueco donc du coup j'ai bloqué une
personne et après je me fais insulter
par d'autres personnes
elle t'a jamais insulté pourquoi tu l'a
bloqué donc là on en parle ce soir mais
je vous dis sincèrement
en fait c'est même pas je m'en fous moi
ils m'ont tous et il est là je m'en fous
parce que j'ai loïc votre bras droit
qu'ont cocon connaît le et qu'il a dit
vous pleurez pas ça va avec
il ya les compliments soit bien seraient
la raison tu prends les compliments sur
twitter si tu veux pas prendre les
insultes tu vas dans ton menu il ya
marqué désactiver se désabonner
c'est ça la solution pour avoir des
abonnés le wiki ma joie vous pleurez
donc on vous assure
moi j'ai jamais pleurer ta gloire à nos
martyrs je suis là j'ai 6 millions de
followers sur twitter
mais c'est normal que sur les 6 millions
y en a qui vont m'insulter bien sûr je
suis bien content je vous le dis quand
je vois qu'à prendre ou à laisser tous
les soirs un bail à des gens qui disent
eh bah c'est formidable et cyril merci
on peut pas avoir que des compliments
jeu mais je joue et ça ne dérange pas
c'est que je n'ai cérébraux on peut
effectivement ne pas ne pas apprécier on
peut ne pas aimer
on peut avoir des désaccords mais en
revanche et l'insultent cela c'est parce
qu'on peut venir on peut s'en passer on
peut dire à calais après voilà qui ne va
pas on va parfaire l'éducation tout le
monde bien sûr
tous ceux qui ne supportait pas les
critiques c est promis qu'ils sont en
train de se gargariser des complices est
vrai en train de les transférer de
l'hérault forward vous dire un truc je
suis bien content chaque année quand y'a
les sondages d'animateurs et que je
pouvais mettre sur votre twitter allez
voter pour moi il c'est vrai que c'est
la vérité
ça fait dix ans et je le jure c'est vrai
et je suis bien content ça fait dix ans
que grâce à ma communauté et grâce à
tous les gens qui me suivent
ça fait dix ans que je gagne tous les
concours d'animateur sur les réseaux
sociaux
parce que voilà j'ai la prose arnaud
c'est donc après je vais pas aller
pleurer parce qu'il ya des mecs qui me
fera casse alors un grand tout va bien
je veux dire ouais bah merci c'est
génial mais c'est normal que tu te
prennes des mecs qui tracasse c'est là
où j'ai regardé il y avait quoi il y
avait il y avait mille huit cents tweets
sur moi sur les 1800 tweet voilà il
devrait avoir moins sept bêtement 50 50
mais c'est normal
voilà déjà la corée du nord s'est collé
mais contrôlable à main c'est la corée
du nord
oui je voudrais juste remettre les
choses à leur place quand loïc vie qu'on
se plaint à aucun moment on s'est plaint
je ne sais pas pourquoi il dit ça sinon
on s'est pas plaint moi aussi on s'est
nommé au plus haut pour l'exemple on
sait pas enclin du tout et on sait on ne
se plaint pas c'est juste qu'à un moment
donné quand une personne vous insulte
sur les réseaux moi la seule démarche
que j'ai étant donné que ray - moi ça
nous touche pas et on ne s'en plaint pas
on chez moi ce que je fais et ce que je
fais sur instagram régulièrement c'est
que je pense à toutes les personnes que
ça atteint et il y en a beaucoup
il ya des gens au collège ya des gens
prient mériel gens lisent et qui se font
harceler par des haters gratuitement et
je pense que nous comme on a un public
et des gens qui nous suivent sur les
réseaux et ben je pense que ça peut être
quand même être sympa pour les gens qui
souffrent de justement prendre la parole
et de dire écoutez regardez c'est la
preuve
voilà la preuve les éliminations peut
elle est pas normal dans sa tête et
impose un sujet mais le romain va vous
aimez mais oui mais là vous parlez à
reparler de ce qui se passe dans les
collèges briser ces deux trucs
complètement différent nous on a choisi
de faire un métier et des prix
n'explosent
vous vous êtes exposés et bah forcément
eh ben vous avez plus de
vous n'êtes plus à chaque épisode c'est
vrai le confesseur fait le professeur
raouya ya six mois personne en parler
dire qu'il est tranquille là maintenant
il a des gens qui l'adorent et qui lui
font des d'odeur et puis demander
d'aider à clé par les journalistes mais
comme par les jeunes médecins un parler
aucun moment où ce plan fait vrai pour
les gens qui se font harceler par ses
biens et ses deux choses différentes
aitor c'est un acteur non mais geoffrey
on est pas d'après moi moi je vais faire
très court sur lighters parce qu'en
finale ça vaut pas le coup qu'on en
parle énormément mais dans la vie il ya
des méchants
il ya des gentils sur internet c'est
pareil soit dans le milieu c'est dans le
soap et de candice ça oui j'aurais voilà
et puis après concernant camélia jordana
moi je crois qu'elle sort un album là
non ouais c'est ça bon ben on est
d'accord on a compris on est d'accord
moi c'est exactement c'est quoi c'est ce
que m'ont dit tous les gens sur twitter
et a plein de gens qui m'ont dit cyril
pourquoi tu te prends la tête mindoro
parce que j'ai un vrai ils m'ont dit à
l'ats fait le buzz et mine de rien a
réussi son coup puisque tout le monde en
a parlé
alors que mine de rien voilà et donc
elle a fait une belle promo au camélia
jordana bravo l non mais c'est ça oui
bernard bien jouer enfin je crois que
les gens la liberté et c'est le fait
même de twitter ou d'instagram de dire
ce qu'ils veulent et nous aussi on a la
liberté de bloquer c'est moi je m'amuse
à bloquer plein de gens ça les deux
pianos qui me dérange abba dégage tu
aurais tu dégages ce sera ma seule
phrase sur un peu différente de vous
parce que la même façon qu'un article
pas si nîmes ont bloqué des jo sur
minitel un article signé me fait chier
une lettre anonyme me fait évidemment
chez et là je déteste ne pas savoir qui
kim qui me détestent ou même qui me qui
m'aiment bien un truc qui me gêne en
profondeur le côté défouloir ne pas
savoir qui c'est jean-michel moi je
bloque jamais mais je critique pas ceux
qui bloquent ce blog j'avais ce que
quelqu'un kim qui vous insulte à ce jour
le lendemain peut vous complimenter bien
sûr bas le complimenter sur les gens ils
ont le droit de connaître dire
aujourd'hui tu as été bon ce que ta mère
et l'enfant n'avait pas été reçue pas
tous en même temps on est si cela on va
pas faire en plus marcher c'est bon mais
encore un mec te dis [ __ ] grosse pub
pour fiat
[Rires]
on peut pas dire ça loncraine kelly au
départ on n'est pas sur nrj 12
d'ailleurs dans la vraie vie de faire ce
qu'elle fait sur twitter c'est bien là
ok c'est vrai j'ai beaucoup appris
notamment plus merci tation l'émission
est bientôt terminée puisqu'on va
pointer un bon doit laisser oui mais
juste pour finir moi je comme j accepte
les compliments quand je suis une des
fois je suis dans mon camion y flotte
j'ai pas le moral je vois plein de gens
qui font des compliments je suis content
samedi bien la seule batterie comme tu
as dix ans décide de venir à la télé ça
va avec les insultes moi je les joies
qui est-il et m'insultait insulté moi
mais ce sera qu'une fois et après ce
sera bloqué moi je voulais même pas
qu'on en parle on en a parlé c'est bien
en plus ce qui est lié à la raison elle
a raison parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui souffrent plus que nous moi je vais
vous dire quand nous insulter je m'en
fous mais alors comme de l'an 40 g ca
vaut utiliser ma dernière je vais bloqué
demain je m'en fous complètement
en tout tu prends le maillage et tu
presses là tu prends le négatif aussi
avec alors on a pris beaucoup de trucs
sur camélia jordana ya un mois je me
suis pris sur camélia le plus souvent
reproché alors pour moi voir puisque
vous avez on va dire d'ailleurs qu'est
ce que vous reprochez on m'a reproché
d'être d'être que dans un sens c'est de
dire que finalement parce que elles
n'étaient pas des cités des cités elle
n'avait pas le droit de parler et les
gens m'ont dit c'est pas parce qu'elle
vient pas des sites et qu'elle a le
droit de parler
on m'a reproché qu'on est tous tombés
dessus tous ensemble mais qu'il n'y
avait pas de contre-pouvoir à part un
peu thierry mais moi ce que je disais
c'était le massacre dont elle parlait
des cités et castaner monsieur k
salaires qui veut aller faire un débat
avec elle en télé c'est sur ça que j'ai
trouvé lunaire est une fois de plus moi
je vous le dis je suis plus dans les
cités donc je pouvais aussi me terrière
dont j'étais pas obligé de partir d'en
arriver je vous le dis on comprend qu à
mediaserv donne son avis on n'a pas dit
qu'elle devait pas dans les choix de vie
nous donne notre avis surtout ici voilà
c'est tout mais après qu'elles demandent
un débat intérieur
là on marche c'est tout cyril on en a
parlé après on n'a jamais nié qu'il n'y
avait pas de violences policières dans
les quartiers on ne l'a jamais nier on
l'a dit sommes en direct au trône a dit
on a préféré des missions avec des
jeunes de banlieues qui souffrent
vraiment
d'abord de certaines pratiques de police
et fritons que camélia jordana qui va
être fatale l'intérieur qui va lui dire
mais là j'ai fait la nouvelle star et je
connais de maintien lui c'est facile
l'huile sur le feu c'est facile rayman
ou qu'ils ont mais quand tu as vite pas
dans les cités c'est facile de parler
comme ça je me répète moi cet après midi
mon souci ce n'était pas de savoir si
l'ascenseur et marche c'était pas de
savoir s'il y avait un tramway ou quoi
c'était le filtre de la piscine
gonflable qui sait encrassé il a fallu
que j'aille au magasin acheter une
piscine moi je suis chez je suis parti
avec en creusant votre machine je suis
passé à cinq ans en dehors de paris je
suis pas obligé moi de venir et de
violet comme ça pour les sites et
nationaux très bien